it's the first time in x-men movies ever
screened-in I'm actually they'll be the
first audience to ever do that Xmen
apocalypse is the story of the most
powerful mutant of all time named
apocalypse what he wants to destroy the
world and up to the x-men to stop them
we find our characters 10 years after
the days of future past I think
everybody except Raven is maybe fairly
chill down at the movies so destroys
their peaks and forces them to fight
again deals with great characters a lot
of fun amazing cast and themes that are
quite universal a story of incredible
epic proportions and then they're going
to experience destruction on a massive
scale and also real emotion there is
bigger more action
there's also a lot more emotion in this
one I think in 3d and imax it's an
immersive experience so everybody's put
everything they've got into the effects
incredible the director and the writer
Simon done incredible job there's a lot
of flying there's a lot of fighting
pretty cool it's epic it's emotional
it's serious too it's very dramatic I
think this is the x-men film that a lot
of fans have been waiting for you can
just have to see it in imax that's what
this movie is paid for and the action is
so powerful and it's just like my face
is right there you're going to watch the
world get ripped apart you probably want
to see it on this biggest screen as
possible you just gotta see it in imax
with otherwise it'll be good but it
won't be the best